what's up guys so we released this
Boston fine Amex video over the weekend
and tricked a lot more people than we
thought we would I just want to break it
down for you guys real quick it's almost
funnier in the new way but more than
anything else it gives you guys a look
as to what we did to make this video
or not
[Music]
[Applause]
as you probably already knew we put a
lot of work into this video took over
three weeks for us to put this together
if you enjoyed it do not forget to
subscribe both to the crew channel and
to the main corridor channel if you
really want to go that extra mile take a
look over at corridor digital now store
pick up some cool merchandise for
yourself it helps support more videos
like this thanks guys